awesome cool well thanks everyone for
sticking around
um
my name is Patrick
um I'm an experimental psychologist and
I study human multi-agent coordination
um the talk I'll give is
um presenting some work using DRL
um led by my office mate garv who
couldn't be here due to Visa reasons so
I made the long Trek to be with you here
today uh and so to start
there we go cool so yeah so working
within teams within um shared physical
or virtual environments I do a lot of
virtual reality social virtual reality
work as well requires the coordination
of attention
um and selection and timing of actions
by each individual agents in order for
them all to contribute meaningfully
towards a shared goal
and of course you know walking or
working together as a collective
um over just working by yourself um has
the obvious benefit of being able to
solve tasks quicker but not only that
working as a team kind of affords the
discovery and exploitation of Novel
strategies that are just not obtainable
to individuals Alone
um and so a really clear example that is
the formation of the Bucket Brigade
where by definition you need other
people in order to officially transport
these objects
and you know success in teams not
guaranteed
um otherwise every competitive sports
game would end in a tie so there's a lot
of variation in terms of the types of
strategies that teams adopt or just how
effective they are in executing those
strategies and my interest in
AI generally is you know we do a lot of
work on developing models replacing
human agents Within These human teams
but not only that I mean I really have
an interest and would love to find
collaborators on just how can we
IntelliJ use these agents to steer
interactions to help um teams discover
these more optimal strategies
as you may know um in DRL
um self-play is used a lot in training
these RL agents and they're really great
these competitive tasks such as go and
DOTA but what was shown in work by Carol
for example is that this typical way of
training agents does not transfer well
or at least not guaranteed um to enable
fluid human AI coordination so in this
case the self-play agent I'm trained
with another self-agent is working with
the green hat which is a human player um
and you get these situations where
you're kind of bumping into each other
and it leads to not as fluid of the
interaction when it comes to serving
onion soup and so their solution was
okay well if you um
endowed the training environment with um
an agent that exhibits kind of human
models um for pre-recorded data and then
have these self-play agents interact
with the human model
um indeed when you do that kind of
approach um it leads to policies that
leads to more effective human AI
collaboration but what if you don't have
access to this human data let's say you
just never did this uh pre uh pre-data
collection or you just don't have
sufficient amounts of data an approach
we use in our lab
um in conjunction with you know
behavioral cloning type approaches is
you can exploit the fact that in
perceptual motor tasks generally complex
human movements can be decomposed into
what are called motor Primitives where
complex actions could be represented as
either being discrete or rhythmic so
discrete actions are you know reaching
for an object throwing a ball where
there's a definite end States and then
rhythmic behaviors are you know waving
your hand walking speaking has a
rhythmicity to it and conveniently for
modeling
you could represent these um dynamical
Primitives using low-dimensional
dynamical systems such that discrete
behaviors could be modeled using fixed
point attractors and rhythmic behaviors
could be represented using limit cycle
Dynamics like a nonlinear oscillator for
example
so what we do in our lab is we compose
models kind of consisting of these
dynamical Primitives to design agents
that could interact with humans
um and we use VR basically we don't have
our own robots so we just do everything
virtual reality and so we do things such
as
um compare using kind of developing
models and comparing for example
individual
um trajectories compared to DRL agents
um Cooperative pick and place tests and
like passing decisions competitive tasks
such as air hockey so looking at the the
postures of kind of attack versus
defense and then kind of also moving
away from these dyadic situations also
considering larger team structures so in
this case this is a four person like
search and rescue kind of task
uh but the bread and butter tests that
we often use um and I think what really
clearly demonstrates the utility of the
dynamical motor Primitives
um is what we call the shepherding task
and um I propose that this is a great
Baseline environment to use in DRL
um in addition to like Hanabi and
overcooked and stuff so hopefully I
could convince you of that and so in
this task
um we have participants come into the
lab and they play on this kind of table
screen here and they have these handheld
controllers and these handheld
controllers control their respective dog
or Shepherd which are these two squares
right here and what participants have to
do is that they have to work together to
find some sort of strategy to Corral and
contain a set of evasive autonomous
agents which are these little balls
which we call sheep and their job is to
keep them contained within that red
circle for a certain amount of time
there are two primary modes of behavior
that we see participants adopt while
doing this task the first of which is
something we call search and recover
where here very early on participants
will intuitively subdivide the task
space in half there's a my side your
side and each player will
um go to the Target that's farthest from
the center and move it towards the goal
location this strategy is relatively
effective if the number of Agents you
have to Corral is relatively low it's
like three for example or if the agents
are really slow moving but as test
difficulty increases this is not a a
useful strategy and at least a task
failure so participants I do have to
note also for this task um this is a
non-verbal no communicate verbal
Communications allowed so people have to
kind of non-verbally negotiate how they
should go about solving this task
um that's pretty much a difference just
the Simplicity of our analyzes
and so over a 45-minute session
um some participants just fail and it
cannot solve this task but for those who
do solve it within this 45 minute period
um we see the spontaneous emergence of a
different mode of behavior which we call
coupled oscillatory containment where
here instead of worrying about each
individual agent participants suddenly
discover that hey what we should do is
just form a wall around this herd and
that does a really good job keeping them
contained
and when we ask participants afterwards
kind of like how do they come about
using the strategy the type of language
they use really does kind of seem to
suggest that it's a moment of cognitive
Insight kind of reorganizing how they
actually perceive the problem itself and
indeed once you discover the strategy
kind of leads to ceiling levels of
performance
um and so what we did in terms of the
modeling front we kind of been using
these kind of like heuristic based
models where
um we took you know taking this Behavior
we decomposed it through different
problems we have the target selection
problem and the action Dynamics how you
move about this environments
for Target selection we just employ a
heuristic-based rule so select the
target that's farthest from the center
that's closer to me than my partner so
we kind of bake in that coordination
within the heuristic role and for Action
Dynamics
um basically just in summary we modeled
uh the behaviors that we observed in
human participants using these dynamical
motor Primitives that I mentioned before
um and the model is capable of
exhibiting both this search and recover
and oscillatory containment as well as
flexibly switch between these two
behaviors
in a kind of human machine interaction
task context we've validated our model
with novice participants um so this is
you know kind of you see like a little
two-dimensional game screen here but
this is kind of embedded within a
virtual reality task where we have
participants come into the lab they put
on a VR headset and they're actually
interacting with another Avatar
completing this task and we tell them
they're interacting with another human
participants and so we kind of do like a
little turing-like test and so in this
case our agents this blue one on the
left it's kind of hard to see but it's
the top one on the right there and so
the Asian is able to work with
participants and solve the task either
in their original configuration just
keep in the red circle and here's a
little bit there's fewer constraints
where you just have to keep them
together just in general anywhere
um and during debriefing
um when asking participants you know to
the extent to which they believed there
was a human partner they're interacting
with most still remain in belief
um that the Avatar was human generated
but there wasn't another participant in
another room
um which provides some evidence that not
only does our model
um is our model able to kind of solve
the task with participants but that it's
able to kind of capture Essences of
human coordinated behavior in these kind
of perceptual motor tasks uh in this
specific perceptional motor task context
so we have this kind of heuristic based
model with this target selection Rule
and a model consisting of dynamical
motor Primitives
and uh you know the problem with your
space models of course is that it's kind
of we engineered it a lot of effort went
into kind of parameterizing it
um and so we're really interested to the
extent to which we could extend our
models to develop agents with
potentially better and more flexible
policies and so the way we go about
doing it is that we kind of treated
um these two components as two separate
things that we could train so you could
do something where we replace the action
Dynamics with a neural network train
that using DRL
um or you know we use these dynamical
motor Primitives make that the uh
movement constraints for the agent and
then have it select
um which Target station select while
doing this task
I also tried like a completely Black Box
approach
um where we had uh two separate neural
networks uh doing both Target selection
action Dynamics however like we just
cannot train it no matter what kind of
curriculum we gave it what kind of
reward shaping um we found it super
difficult so maybe
um for those who have strong
computational DRL backgrounds you could
help us out there
um
but yeah this is the summarize the
training we implemented this curriculum
whereas this 11-step process where we
slowly increase the number of agents
that had to be crowded as well as
increase their speed slowly and the
reward structure was just that
we gave them positive feedback if all
the targets were within the red circle
negative if they were too far away and
then we also
um provided a small negative feedback if
uh they were too close to each other
just kind of promote this division of
labor type strategy
and so these are just some result um
just a summary of the training results
so on the x-axis is just the the
curriculum steps and then this is the
cumulative training steps needed
um and probably unsurprisingly so when
you be constrained an agents to use our
dynamical Primitives and it just had a
train which targets it should select was
able to go through a curriculum in the
fastest amount of time followed by the
agent that had to discover its own
action Dynamics policy
and like I said we couldn't really train
a black box agent but what we did is
that we provided information directly
about which targets select so we
basically mimicked this policy here and
then at some point during the curriculum
learning we then allowed it to develop
its own Target selection policy and then
you can see that you know it takes
longer to get through the curriculum
which may not be surprising right
because we basically are reducing the
dimensionality of the pro of the
training problem
um
but what was more important for us is
kind of testing to see the extent to
which
um these agents are able to actually
collaborate with humans in the in this
kind of shepherding task that we have
and the way we did that is we use this
kind of um training
uh and transfer task like approach where
we'll have participants come into the
lab and they'll have to play with one of
our agents that we developed either a
heuristic based agent or one that is
um either trained using or with a neural
network
um and then during after training uh
we'll do this transfer task where it's
similarly trained individuals come
together and do a modified version of
the task that they haven't seen before
that has kind of uh yeah a new objective
and just to summarize uh what we did um
this is our just results from this this
paper here
um so for this paper we only um did the
comparison between our heuristic based
model and a model where how to develop
its own action Dynamics uh policy so
here we're basically fixing the
perception side and then really
comparing um the action Dynamics side
and what we find is that during training
participants are able to complete the
training at higher levels of performance
with the artificial agent and exhibit
more oscillatory behaviors during
um the transfer task that level of skill
persists with the new part partner
compared to this model here and then we
also have a separate sample where we
had participants interact with our
various agents and they preferred
working with a heuristic based model as
opposed to the one where the action
model was trained using DRL of course
the critical step is you know this all
this other option here which we're in
the active data collection Force I don't
have those results for you but hopefully
in a couple months you know we'll have
that as well
so kind of the summarize the findings is
that basically for agents who are
constrained using these dynamical motor
primitive models
um are able to collaborate with humans
in this task context and are the
preferred models compared to an agent
whose action policy was trained using
DRL
um and just kind of just a preview of
some of our future work um we're kind of
now looking into like the perceptual
side so looking at kind of these
policies that are um training that's I'm
sorry these networks are trained to do
Target selection
um there's a student um recently
graduate student named retail looking uh
using expandable AI techniques to kind
of differentiate novices versus experts
as well as the decision making
um behaviors of these different policies
um to see kind of what are the input
features that are most important that
differentiates
um those who discover these strategies
versus those who don't
um but just to conclude
um as I only was given 10 to 15 minutes
um is that you know despite the
potential complexity and human behavior
um the goal directed Behavior generally
is very low dimensional in nature and
shows kind of dynamic similitude across
context
um and then kind of summarize that point
basically you know as agents interact
with their environment
um there's these dynamics that are
generated based on their interaction
which could be summarized using
um what are called behavioral Dynamic
models or task Dynamic models which you
could formalize as dynamical systems
um which are what these dynamical motor
Primitives are composed of and then once
these Dynamics are generated right you
could have this kind of top-down process
that kind of constrains you know kind of
like this realization process where you
kind of realize these Dynamics and then
an agent could then exploit them
explicitly and these types of dynamical
models translates to different
environments so I've only talked about
this tabletop task but we also done some
other work where we actually had people
navigate a virtual environment through
Locomotion to solve this task and even
though in this case the behaviors look
different
um they're both predictive from the same
dynamical model and you know I love like
BBC documentaries and so right there's a
lot of similitude of what we see in
other animal systems
um so I just want to give a shout out to
garv he's the one who did all the DRL
work I did the shepherd the original
shepherding work Lily's done the human
AI preference comparison study and then
I mentioned fabriza who recently PhD is
doing the explainable AI stuff as well
so thank you so much yeah I'll take any
questions may have
[Applause]
thank you Patrick yep that was amazing
any question
it's
hi thanks for that talk it's really
interesting I'm just gonna get some
water while you ask yep
um first off I think I might beat you in
terms of travel distance I had to travel
two hours from Adelaide to Sydney and
then then come here so you're my
Adelaide person okay yeah okay awesome
awesome okay I was wondering where you
were okay cool darn okay I got second
place then okay
I um I was wondering in the cases uh in
the Dr uh in the Deep reinforcement
learning where it where the humans
weren't preferring yeah play with the um
the reinforcement learning um agent yeah
I was wondering is that because the um
the reinforcement learning agent was
forming social conventions
um that the humans weren't able to
interact with well so I just trying to
get some insight into why you might
think the humans didn't prefer the
reinforced learning agent yeah so good
thing I have some backup slides just in
case
um I think maybe I could do this one
this one's based in simula oh these can
be so hard to see
um but you know it's kind of like
obvious stuff okay so you maybe see
there's a little cyan dot right here I
believe that one is the
that model it's you know it's typical
behaviors right is that um the movement
behaviors are very jittery for example
um and so it's able to uh granted this
is it's this is interacting with one of
our heuristic models
um
it's just
I think it's the level of noise um I
actually haven't interrogated the video
so much um compared to garof who like I
said was leaving this project
um but that's the general idea is that
our heuristic based model
um oh I guess yeah sorry well heuristic
based model in this particular section
usually we have like a social coupling
term
um so that the behaviors of the agent is
directly coupled to the of the partner
in this case we didn't include that
coupling term to make it more
um comparable I believe
I think you could quote me on that I'm
like blinking now
um but yeah further further
investigation we'll kind of have to see
exactly what aspects of the behavior but
just from visual inspection of these
videos it's just kind of one of those
obvious things where it's like you know
the politics is developing because
remember there's a continuous control
problem as well you know it's kind of
you know adding more Jitter and stuff
like that um does that answer a little
bit of your question otherwise I could
yeah forward you to garif um who would
be able to tell you everything about
that yeah yeah cheers I might um grow
his details uh after this yeah yeah for
sure yeah thank you yeah yeah thank you
hi uh thanks for our talk I really
enjoyed it oh thank you um 40 tasks that
you proposed is the kind of wall
um like the policy where they just kind
of form a wall yeah on on the top and
bottom yes is that the is that like the
single
um optimal policy that exists because in
that case um yeah you know you can just
have your agents play in in self-play
and that would really only be yeah I
mean like that would be like the only
convention that you really need yeah so
I'll just play like these videos too um
just as an example in the background
um this this is about something
different just again showing how these
behaviors are emergent kind of for free
using you know kind of taking like a
self-organization kind of story
um and what we see is that
um it is based on kind of the
constraints acting upon human systems so
because they're interacting at a
tabletop they can only reach so far for
example
the best type of policy as a human user
you can adopt
is something like this
um and right you have to remember like
assuming this was human participants in
this example yeah you have physical
embodied arms right and so you can't
like for example move around in a circle
effectively because you bump into each
other
um and so yeah so in a two-person case
on the tabletop you see something like
this
um in full body Locomotion what you see
instead is that people kind of spin
around the entire herd because they
don't have that constraint of the arms
for example in a single player case
um this is what our transfer task was
you can just adopt this kind of
circular-like behavior
um so right the key is like forming a
circle of some sort right
um however that kind of circle circle
idea isn't a obvious solution to most
participants at the very beginning and
that's something that needs to be
discovered
um but uh through this simulation work
um
it does seem to suggest yeah depending
on the cons you know depending on the
constraints acting on the animal and the
type of environment it's in you do see
kind of differences in how the policy is
kind of is you know unfolding
um but it could be explained by the same
dynamical model yeah hopefully that
answers your question yeah thank you
um you kind of answered my question on
that one because I was going to say like
I don't know if I misheard you but it
sounded like the agents had some sort of
penalty for getting close to each other
yeah yeah yeah so I was thinking this
whole
like oscillation Behavior I was
intrigued why an agent would learn that
and not go in a circle yeah but the fact
that uh this is played on a tabletop
yeah yeah so yeah yeah so um yes exactly
so do they in this case do
um
do the learning agents play a sort of
best response to whatever the human
behavior is
it is
um
so what's given as in sorry saying um
the agents trained using DRL or your
yeah oh yeah so the inputs for that so
it'll receive just the states of the
environment
um it'll just select whatever action and
it just does that because it's like it's
like whatever Target it wants so yeah it
doesn't again for I mean with the
penalty hopefully it's inferring that if
my partner is pursuing this target I
shouldn't pursue that one
um but that's not guaranteed yeah okay
so like but the the human starts playing
and then and then the uh RL agent is
just kind of acting in conjunction with
wherever the human is yeah yeah so it's
updating yeah so yeah
so did the human
um discover that kind of Half Moon
oscillating policy oh yeah so um there
will be some so yeah so what we see is
that with the DRL agents you do see that
you do see that behavior emerge um not
the same level
um compared to our heuristic based model
so it is possible but yeah not at levels
that we see when participants would work
with another human or if our heuristic
based model
um but yeah okay very cool thanks yep